lights
like the little ones like Yoni uses yeah
right right I was thinking about that
but it's like the same price
to light everything up yeah
I might uh
I might put in a green screen
where at on this wall yeah and then it
kind of wraps around over here that
would be cool because then you could
like put us anywhere you really wanted
to yeah I don't know if it'd be big
enough
I think I could be angled a little more
towards your direction maybe I can do it
with
just like this
nice 50 50.
so
yeah
what do you think about
Joe Biden
um
I think that he's one practical prank
away from being assassinated you know
what I mean like if he does a prank no
if someone put like a one practical
prank on him
he would die yeah like if I decided to
be like uh some type of Jackass
character and kick the leg out of his
lawn chair for fun that fall would kill
him yeah yeah
that's that's that's who we that's the
strength and resilience we need to be
the figurehead of our country
without getting too political
well physically he's not that fit
I saw a picture of him 26 same age as me
right now in uh Santa Barbara California
last night he's a handsome guy
and it was weird to look at him and be
like
just to think he had like the same type
of brain processes as me at 26 maybe and
you're like does that guy know he's
going to be president one day yeah and
then I thought I don't think he knows
he's [ __ ] president right now
I don't think he ever got the the
satisfaction of the situation no yeah he
doesn't feel the the you know that that
Vigor that [ __ ] ah I did it right do
you think he [ __ ]
not well I don't think he's [ __ ] his
wife looks great for her age she's
throwing it
do you think why he uh soaks
I think that's in the tub in his wife
and his wife he's just a soak he's a
soak guy yeah
I don't know I would hope that it'd be
crazy to go back in time and be like hey
you're going to be president someday and
he's like oh my God what about 70 years
from now yeah he's like what I have to
wait 70 years I'm gonna live that long
people don't live that long back then
people didn't live that long yeah
I don't know I think that's the safest
choice though if you were to choose
anybody to lead a country would be the
oldest possible candidate I think that's
what the book of The Giver is about yeah
or something like that like you ever
yeah remember that we all read in high
school middle school stay golden Ponyboy
whatever that's uh The Outsiders yeah
okay yeah but the The Giver is about
like oh the memory lies with this guy
and he's passing it down by touching him
yeah he's got to touch little boys
that's what he's doing yeah he's putting
their hands in their hair and giving
them what it felt like to be 26 and
that's how I felt when I was molested
yeah
and
[Music]
um
I never mind
I was gonna say
it had to have been easier to get away
with molestation back then definitely
they didn't even know what it was
they're like oh Grandpa's doing the
touchy touchy that's how communion is
given what are you talking about yeah
yeah
um but I think that uh uh The Giver you
know it's like they can't see color
because color is too dangerous right
they're genetically engineered like
biome of people right yeah they got rid
of hills
Hills are bad really yeah in the in the
book I forgot about that part and
obviously went down sledding and he was
like what was that yeah
and then uh
because that's like the memory he had
yeah that's insane yeah that's just what
Americans are afraid of they're like we
might not have health care but at least
we have our freedoms is that the
metaphor you think yeah we're just
constantly congratulating ourselves for
like basic things that humans have like
you know we don't have any labor rights
or affordable housing yeah but at least
we have
uh I saw recently someone like unionized
their simple labor job and they got like
a sixteen thousand dollar a year raise
and I was like that's incredible
I guess yeah I mean we should get a
share the profits if you're working for
a company you shouldn't just get paid
the minimum amount possible Right to
survive do you think Comics will ever be
able to successfully unionize
I don't think it's a job that's
necessary or like they have a film
Actors Guild that's true
[ __ ] yeah that is what it is called just
a bunch of it's the [ __ ] group yeah that
makes sense yeah I mean yeah eventually
but there's always someone willing to do
what we do right that's what I always
say the same with actors actors are
desperate as [ __ ]
but they managed to unionize because if
you don't it's just so sad it's just so
you're so easily manipulatable that's
right now though I mean how many comedy
shows I mean you I don't know like I do
comedy shows for 20 bucks all day every
day every day of the week like and I'm
like yeah it took me five minutes that's
how much most of the shows bring in
right like a lot of those shows bring in
a lot yeah you can't ask for too much
yeah I mean you go to a show and you got
13 people sitting in the audience you do
the basic math you're like that's 260
bucks or whatever yeah sitting here and
I'm asking for 50 bucks yeah
so then they're only getting the bar
money which then you have to buy the
alcohol and pay the bartender
yeah and then you you basically be
unionizing to create better show
producers
that's what it would be at the end of
the day yeah okay why don't you actually
advertise this yeah and then pay me you
have to have a good show yeah it
incentivize us to make better shows
yeah recently I became like comfortable
with the idea of
being like fiscally stagnant as a comic
and then like there even if there are
like future successes in store it
doesn't guarantee steady work so I'm
just like comfortable with the idea of
living broke artists like for the rest
of my life yeah and that took a lot of
weight and stress off my shoulders yeah
you don't have to have a Bugatti no I'm
just like as long as I can pay my bills
I can figure out how to buy a beer at
the comedy club every night
yeah I mean that's fun you know you
might not be getting money but like what
does uh money really mean anyways but I
think like the financial rewards aren't
always matching the artistic rewards
it's like [ __ ] crazy like sometimes
you get a lot of financial rewards and
not for doing anything super artistic
yeah like doing The Comedy Store
recently was a a truly intrinsic
valuable situation like I was like to
someone else this may have been like
yeah I'll take five bucks to tour the
comedy store but to me it was like
infinitely priceless
and then uh like I could have been paid
nothing but it like you're saying it's
the
there's an artistic value to it all that
yeah that makes it like I could have
died that night in a weird way it would
have been content I'd like to have
children and raise them to be successful
adults oh yeah uh it was uh
you're right you got to be at The Comedy
Store yeah
yeah I mean you get like the idea that
you fit into like a grander thing and
part of something larger and
see yourself in that light and how you
can contribute right it was nice a buddy
from high school hit me up and that was
like first it's one of the first things
in my comedy career where I think other
people have been like hey that's really
cool man you made it and I'm like made
it
that's comical that's the funniest thing
I've ever heard yeah well most people
have no idea what comedy is or what art
is or what craft right getting good at
something they all they know is
promotion and corner office and all that
so like that like the signs the
the feathers the fromage of success is
all that they have and this symbols
right in our definition of success is so
wildly different just because yeah
because we're out there talking to
people every day we're looking them in
the eye and being like Oh that made that
person feel horrible right let me try
not to do that exactly
or you're like having a drink at 11AM 11
p.m and it's Tuesday
and that's just part of the the like the
theme of the night it doesn't even
matter you're just like this is how I am
yeah like the David tell type joy that
you get right I have buddies who get off
Friday and they're like hell yeah I can
have my couple beers I'm like well you
can have a couple beers on Wednesday man
and still go to work on Thursdays yeah
my sense of the weekend is so like every
day is a weekend like there is no
weekend every every day is the weekday
and the weekend yeah today was two
today's Tuesday Wednesday it's Wednesday
it's a Wednesday what do we do today uh
you woke me up at like noon 30. I was
like yeah I can be ready in 17 minutes
or whatever and then [ __ ] I fell back
asleep on the recliner woke up to your
phone call again I got woken up by Hans
twice today what time did you sleep last
night I went to bed at 4 30 a.m though
me too I went to bed at five doing what
Katan and then I ate and then I went to
bed that's about what I was doing I was
uh
watching that new scary movie Barbarian
I only heard about everyone's talking
about it it was good I was hoping it'd
kind of be a little bit more uh edgy and
grotesque but it ended up being like I
laughed
is that the one where they have a
trailer where the girl's like I stayed
here at the Airbnb and then she finds
like a secret passageway right
yeah that's like always a thing that's
like the thing in uh the World Trade
World Fair in Chicago where the guy uh H
Holmes yeah yeah
I've talked about this on a couple of
their podcasts but there's an
interesting theory that H.H Holmes is
Jack the Ripper and before Jack the
Ripper was Jack the Ripper he was the
slave girl slaughterer
here in Austin they're all the all
connected all the same guy
they think that he killed like three or
four ladies uh
like servant girls that's what it was
called the servant girl Slaughter
here and then when the heat got high on
him he left to Europe and then basically
proceeded doing the exact same type of
killing of the exact same type of woman
and then they said like maybe he
developed so much as a killer in Europe
that when he came back for the world
fair as H.H Holmes as an older man he
was just like methodical at that point
but he got caught HH holds to get caught
yes
so it could have been that good uh well
not until the very end he had built like
a like a 20 bedroom house with like
multiple torture rooms and like gas
Chambers and stuff like if I think he he
maxed it out I think he went out on top
this is awesome right I think that uh he
like he had different Builders like he'd
fire them and fire new ones yeah no one
had the full scope of it right hey you
put in this gas pipe into this room with
one window staring into it it's like
what's that for no you're fired you
asked too many questions
yeah he had to have money
yeah but I mean if you're killing people
and you can like take their identities
that feels like in a time where you can
like maybe if there's a an account you
can if you're seeing Talented Mr Ripley
yeah same thing it's like 1960s or
whatever you could easily just be like
someone else withdraw all their money
yeah it's fascinating to be like what
would happen if I attacked everyone all
the time
I don't know up until like the 1930s you
were allowed to just kill your wife
tell the town that she was a floozy and
then Mary again and your kids would have
a new mom but they would be like that's
kind of not polite that's unseemly if
you keep killing your wives we're like
yeah why this guy this guy can't hold a
woman down and then Meanwhile your well
is getting Fuller and Fuller and Fuller
every day yeah it's like oh she must
have gone to the Oregon Trail yeah
what's crazy is we're like 70 80 years
out from that being the norm that was
not a norm I think it was I think a lot
more I think a lot of people were dying
by murder more back then well yeah
definitely more than now but I think
like the majority of people were getting
along and figuring it out
big brother didn't exist yet though
I cannot say with absolute certainty
that if you put me in 1935 and give me
like a Hatfield and McCoy type Coral
with a neighbor
and I knew there was no consequence to
just kill that person and the lack of
Education the lack of moral standing in
the like geolocation of where I was at I
probably could have easily killed
somebody
I feel I mean it's in us it's uh it's
it's definitely a part of us that we
experience that isn't very pleasant
yeah no it's the worst I just admitted
to to murder back in the day
yeah I think there's something fun to
acknowledging that part of us yeah uh
you have to if you're ignoring it that's
even worse because that means it's
bubbling up inside you without any
conscious yeah checking neglecting your
carnal efforts yeah yeah
it'd be interesting to know how much the
brain needs to kill like we hunt and
there's like a release from that yeah I
mean when you are only surrounded by
people then your only frame of reference
for prey is going to be other people
it's not like we're hanging out with
deer and you know other animals yeah
it's not a part of our life so we have
these carnivorous predatory instincts
and then the only prey that we see is
other people so it's gonna if you let
that develop we're just gonna start
attacking each other
right it's like a the Dahmer thing he
did the whole his I think the Taxidermy
is what fried him in the early onset
alcoholism
like what do you mean he taxed her he
saw a lot of Taxidermy his dad taught
him how to be a taxidermist as a child
like he was right he was fascinated by
like a dead rat they found out of the
house and they wanted it to like strip
it to its bones
and I don't know at the time as a parent
you can't be like no go inside and play
with the iPad don't look at this you're
like yeah let's teach you how to do this
it's the perfect mix of modern and
primal yeah
yeah
nature versus nurture it's like no it's
it's both do you think it's like a
cultural thing like we are in a you know
dog eat dog
heedless capitalist Society where we're
just trying to attack each other
financially and that's sort of the
mindset and so we're gonna attack each
other physically since that's what we're
doing to each other economically
right
I don't you ever heard like the thing
it's like do something and then pretend
like it was on purpose
I think it's like
maybe governing bodies are just [ __ ]
up so bad that when it goes bad they're
like we plan this demise this was the
demise was the plan part not the uh
project we had going that failed
miserably yeah they'd rather act like
they have control over it than admit
that they're just sort of not good at
what they do right I mean who's to say I
don't know why are we wrote the last
three years there's been
a new generation of the Romanticism I
can never say this word
romantic
romanticization yeah Rome that
mentalization romanticization
romanticization
uh I think it would be
like I wouldn't be surprised if 20 years
from now or 25 years from now there's
some seven or eight-year-old watching
that show and they shouldn't be
and growing some demented thoughts in
their head right now yeah I think we
should I hate that everyone's obsessed
with it like yesterday they were
watching that guy and what Keisha that
ran into a bunch of people he's on trial
now and it's televised that happened in
Europe or Washington and Wisconsin
well Keisha yeah that was the uh the
parade thing right parade yeah
yeah I don't want to hear this guy's
thoughts like this is not like we have
empathy and like you can't just like
shoot your mirror neurons to anything
and everything
like you have to be careful what enters
your brain yeah and I feel like just
empathizing with like crazy people and
like the Joker and Jeffrey Dahmer I just
feel like it's not the best thing for
your head it's definitely putting oil on
the slope yeah all you have to do now is
step off and you're gonna have all these
scary thing is like people think that
makes sense right now they're like I
might have to do that let me prepare
myself because we all feel this sort of
impending doom yeah
I think that's a yeah it's a pretty good
takeaway I mean it's like how much talk
we're talking about that South Park
episode you know the kicker Ginger Day
people gingers really didn't catch much
Flack before that episode I didn't know
that I did no idea that that [ __ ]
Ginger so hard but the whole idea of the
episode in true like
uh South Park fashion is that it's
ridiculous to marginalize any group of
people for the smallest right but not
everyone will get that message that way
eight and ten-year-olds just thought it
was like yeah Kick a Ginger Day is a
real thing now yeah it's like fun yeah
so Ginger Kids actually ended up like
killing themselves and [ __ ] like that
yeah because of a team because of a
cartoon yeah because they put this meme
in their head this idea right so you
don't like the Inception that because I
watched Dahmer I'm not thinking about
possible ways to refrigerate ahead I
think it's in do you see it yeah I
watched the first two episodes and was
like this is like handmaid's tale it's
like why am I gonna constantly give
myself an anxiety attack why do I want
to empathize with a man who thought he
was gonna get [ __ ] in the ass and then
ended up almost being murdered yeah
that's not an experience I need to
Insight on yeah I'm not gaining anything
from it
it's the same thing every time it's like
I would never would have gone in that
house
I would have smelt the things and just
been like oh that's what everyone says
yeah I've never been horny that's the
thing oh yeah yeah you probably would a
girl yeah but that's like uh like if if
our lives are like uh you know not
exciting and we're like living safer
than we ever have but we feel this weird
sort of Stress and Anxiety it's like uh
well you know at least I'm not getting
murdered like oh let me prepare myself
against the only danger that I will face
this is like us watching Bear Grylls
yeah
except for we know we're never going to
get stranded in the wilderness yeah I'm
much more likely to become a predator to
a serial killer yeah
yeah there's a serial killer right now
in La I found that out when I was out
there and it's a weird one because he's
just walking up and shooting people
without any type of before interaction
or anything yeah it's like a what's his
name Son of Sam situation
that to me is scarier than being held
captive and tortured to death because
that's more likely yeah way more I mean
your life's just over you got any higher
buildings around here that are taller
than these windows like I'm always
thinking about it luckily those shades
are closed yeah luckily no one wants to
kill me
they mapped this place out I mean that's
the uh Clock Tower of the UT campus yeah
that's uh the reason SWAT exists
Nationwide after that failure as a
response of law enforcement they created
SWAT so they could handle situations
like that and now you've already
happened and so yeah it's like how many
SWAT teams do you need you need a SWAT
team in every Uvalde sized city now I
did something just came out where like I
think like their entire police force was
let go it was something like that it
makes sense I mean they do that for like
[ __ ] yeah that's really sad it's a
tragic one uh yeah especially I don't
know what they were thinking like as a
cop isn't this what you live for and as
like a big NRA component State Texas
brushes these things we find a way to
milk them for three months and then milk
them dry to the point where after three
months it's just like yeah that's in the
past now Seguin people forgot all about
Seguin what's the game exactly it was a
church that was shot up like 23 people
were killed or something like that with
a hunting rifle like it was barbaric and
then someone who was loading it each
time it was something crazy like that
and then he he was shot by someone there
so it was like an NRA success story but
the truth is like yeah it's it's it was
maybe not 23 is too much but I remember
it being more than it was a double-digit
thing it one is too much but
it's uh it's scary how like remember
Sandra Bland yeah yeah I've that's still
I think about her almost every day
because it's such a mystery that she
just ends up dead with no suicidal
pre-convention in a Texas jail cell yeah
and then
she's constantly mentioned through like
BLM movements and stuff like that but
it's it I think it's bigger than that I
mean it goes to show that law
enforcement can do whatever they want
with you once they arrest you yeah
you're just a physical body right and
then once again Texas can push it away
because they're like that's a some weird
victory in a sense
well yeah the letting go of the whole
police force is a good step I think I
think this it sends a message yeah and
it's like the police force is never
really that uh you never know how good
it is until you need them and then when
something like this happens it's like
[ __ ] that they weren't good and like
more kids died than they should have and
right
um yeah it's like a [ __ ] uh fire
extinguisher like you never know until
you have to need it in Texas you can buy
a gun and walk out with it the same day
a handgun now too yeah that's what I did
when I bought mine I helped uh I run
that show at the gun store
and last number they're a comic bought a
gun
and he purchased it hammered
like not hammered drunk
and was able to go home with it that
night
I was like yeah you should pick it up
tomorrow but
um and my both my brothers worked in
pawn shops for a long time and you can
go into a pawn shop and buy an assault
rifle today for a cut rate
like it's yeah it's amazing there aren't
more shootings yeah and the thing is is
like that's a pawn shop and no knock to
my little brothers or anything but
neither one of them have completed in
higher education system yet and they're
both very thoughtful individuals and
they've told me times but they didn't
have to be no and there's people who are
like well I'll make eight percent off
this gun sell either way
yeah and then like that'll pay for their
Hulu subscription to hear about the
documentary of the shooting they caused
a few months later yeah
they're all part of it but no one is
really responsible for any any of it I
think you should have to like jump
through quite a bit of Hoops to purchase
a firearm for your for mental health at
this point we've come as far as a
country to the point where it's like why
not vet us all yeah
like they should listen to this podcast
listen to what I just said about killing
my wife in 1930 and then decide we can't
give this guy a firearm he's a loose
cannon
yeah guns are fun though they're a blast
literally
yeah I might grew up shooting skeet I
grew up hunting so it's a
I think I have the mindset of it being a
tool
more than other people who have never
handed like firearm until they're an
adult uh like I've seen a shotgun used
to break something to get in like it's
they're they're they're they're they're
tools is it a slug yeah one time I shot
a squirrel with Buckshot that was
hanging on a tree and I thought I had a
rat shot in and just like grabbed the
wrong shell and loaded it because uh
when you're on the ranch
like you don't even have the gun loaded
on the thing typically that's how we do
it we you know it's a shotgun and then
you the map the clip is a separate or
the the shells were separate and then
every time you need to use it you load
it
uh and I reached and grabbed like a buck
shot shell and put it it's a buck shot
so there's rat shot which is like little
tiny BBS is what you would imagine and
then Buckshot is like lumps of lead like
it'll tear a hole through this like
yeah it'll blast a hole through it well
like that big yeah and it's I mean if it
hits something it's gonna blow it to
Pieces it's like a shrapnel fire
and uh this all that was left was like
the tail sitting at the base of the tree
and then the owner of the ranch like
kicks open the ranch house door he's
like what the [ __ ] is going on because
there's a louder round too it's really
it looks just smoke a chunk of the tree
missing and a squirrel and then my
buddies are laughing at me because
they're like we were kidding man you
shouldn't have shut up that squirrel I
was like I'm gonna do it I like Barrel
rolled outside of the cart
it's fun yeah
that's crazy
oh yeah
um yeah I love guns um I only have one
is it a handgun yeah okay nine
millimeter yeah Glock uh it's like a
Glock it's a shadow systems mr920 it's a
long longer Barrel nice it's like a
little fancier yeah like a customized
gun yeah it's like yeah they made they
put a little extra stuff on it I don't
really know that's cool though yeah it's
fun to use and it's fun to shoot just to
like make a little tight little uh
groupings you should do a podcast pop
one podcast pop uh just shoot it one
time for the Middle East blow these mics
out
with the high filter on yeah it's so
[ __ ] loud it's crazy oh we go deaf if
you shot that in here I don't know how
you shoot guns like they show it in
movies like they're in a room struggling
yeah you go deaf yeah there's no way
yeah unbelievable how loud it is it's
like crazy that we still need to use
chemicals it's like powders it's like
witchcraft the guns are yeah yeah it's a
controlled explosion yeah that pushes
something you're like sending a rocket
man through someone's body every single
time you do it yeah
like I don't know how you shoot guns
without hearing protection on you go
deaf yeah I really think you're outside
it helps but yeah you put that little
thing on and you put the filter on so
that you can still hear like tactically
like people coming around but right yeah
like in the Ukraine they always have
like hearing protection on
I would say I couldn't imagine what like
artillery fire would sound like
it's like the 20s yeah have you seen the
pictures of like the guys who go into
before and after of World War One World
War II and how like much the age yeah
it's gonna be a nightmare to sit there
and hear like explosions go off around
you it's nice it's nice and comfortable
in this podcast studio in Austin Texas
God forbid we're in Kiev right now yeah
that's crazy I don't think that's ever
going to end I think they found the new
Middle East
what Ukraine I think so it's just gonna
go slowly deeper into white people
territory until it reaches America yeah
we're just gonna slowly colonize
ourselves pipelines and winners about to
start we're just slowly dividing the pie
into thinner and thinner slices right
but yeah the answer is just treating
each other nicely because it's the right
thing to do instead of just trying to
get as much as possible regardless of
the social impact
I think it should be like robots
fighting like Call of Duty each country
should send their best Cod players and
then well maybe it should be like such a
esoteric thing like listen we all need
War so we're just gonna have it in this
server like they're gonna be fighting
and whoever wins determines who gets the
oil pipeline it's the hunger game it's
the constructed Hunger Games at that
point everybody has to get in uh you can
send who you want or you can we can
elect them yeah and like we all need to
do War but it is too costly physically
yeah let's just do it digitally do you
think that'll get to the point because
it used to be is like I'm gonna kill as
many as your people
then more than you're gonna kill mine
but now it's like war is a fiscal game
yeah so I wouldn't be surprised if it
maybe went into like an Ender's Game
type of thing where it was like oh they
don't have the Bots to put up anymore
it's like an auction I bid 1500 right
nobody has to die it's come down to
complete Sport and then the winner of
the tournament wins whatever the
negotiations were
I think it's easier to imagine that than
it is to imagine us getting along
peacefully
it's easier to imagine that yeah yeah
yeah
it's easier to imagine the end of the
world than it is to imagine the end of
capitalism
it's like why can't we just like [ __ ]
get along and you know right stop trying
to take as much like like you said like
you're happy being like a working class
comic like if everyone had that then we
wouldn't need to keep trying to make
Finance Bros and buy more cocaine and do
the most expensive but I think I was
able to get to that level of like
content because uh
I mean I think I had the education to I
mean to be content where I am now I have
the education also to let myself up and
go to bigger things if I'd like but
ultimately I think I learned at a
younger age and at an older age like you
need what you need and you get what you
get and then generally speaking
happiness is momentary contentness is
like long term so
I don't it's probably a weird weak
survival thing for me and the fact that
I know I can sustain working class comic
a lot longer than I probably could going
for it and then eating this is like the
big time failures you know over and over
again there's probably something
subconscious to that
But ultimately it's an education thing I
think if we educate everyone properly we
can all get to a point where you can say
I can split my piece of bread
nutritionally I'll survive so it's
people are so selfish yeah
you grew up in America I don't know
where this education came from but I had
good parents good parents that uh I
think a lot of it we talked about
religion earlier when we're eating but
Lutheranism
was super impactful to me uh Martin
Luther Martin Luther is like we're not
doing Catholicism anymore yeah the guy I
learned Christianity from essentially
was like nah it's it's not it's a
spiritual thing he really believed in
value of self other over than what I
need to give you to receive something I
think that's huge especially the time he
was doing it and then he was just like
this bad he took he's like okay I'm
gonna show you 100 reasons why and I'm
gonna nail him to your front [ __ ]
door and that'll be that so that was
like don't go with the flow Just Do Your
Own Thing
yes I'd say that sir in a simple yeah it
uh
yeah I mean that and I should never have
to pay anybody to fill something I can
accomplish myself
like you're telling yourself resilience
yeah like I don't gotta go to heaven to
pay you to go to heaven
to pay you to go to an escape room and
get out or whatever but I'm not gonna at
least you get something out of that yeah
I took mushrooms and sat in a dark room
I don't need to pay anyone to go to
heaven yeah like it's a
I'd say I got it tattooed on my arm
Lutheran Rhodes but it's it was such a
it's such a
Pinnacle and then this is the the Cairo
the sign of the crucifixion because I
believe in sacrifice too
and like I'd say that's the education I
don't think it was formal I received
formal education later on like an
emotional knowledge spiritual knowledge
how to be happy with yourself yeah
that's good yeah I mean I don't think
it's hard to teach everyone no
I think it's it's most the time it's
people realizing that you're trying too
hard yeah you're doing too much so the
Protestant work ethic
you you uh you're like I'm going back to
Lutheranism uh not completely I'd like I
said I don't I don't my faith right now
is pretty diminished but I do believe
like whatever yeah the myths that speak
deeper to the soul than facts or like
animal facts or random equations could
ever get to I mean we're uh we're just
animals like the things that speak to us
and move us aren't necessarily
math yeah someone brought up Pilates to
me recently about animals and uh the Mr
Pilates that was like his actual last
name uh it's like you ever hear
something you're like yeah no one could
ever be named that again like Hitler
Pilates Lincoln yoga like it's Lincoln
yeah uh
it's apparently he grew up on a farm and
he studied the way animals move
naturally and he thought that that was
integral to
core strength and how because animals
don't move with an emotional purpose
they move completely for logistical
reasons yeah and he demise that uh
device I don't know God damn I'm [ __ ]
Billy full of pork belly and uh he uh
it was like the core is everything
everything these animals do eventually
stabilizes their core and that's why
Pilates is such a core based strength
training yeah Central node right but it
originally like he uh he wanted to do it
because
people crippled from war
he's like well what do we need to train
so that you're able to do everything
else it's like well it's the core once
you get your core strong enough you can
start to lift your arm or something like
that
yeah yeah ABS yeah I think that
that speaks to back to like our natural
Inquisition to
like as animals
there's parts of us inside too that we
have to like nourish you have to be
spiritually okay otherwise you're going
to go about you're gonna make decisions
you should make you think what you say
you say what you do you do who you are
for yeah spiritual core yeah you really
gotta have that strong yeah my my
physical core is mushy but my spiritual
core is unbendable it's kind of yeah
it's great right yep on your arm all
right do spiritual sit-ups every morning
[Music]
and you're a recliner yeah woken up
that's what I did I woke up you text me
I stretch I do I stretch every morning I
breathe and I I uh I breathe every
morning too right
I subscribe to the be here now method or
whatever and I really try to feel like
I'm in my own body today yeah and that
we're gonna experience today every day
and that's kind of important to me
that's good that way you're not like
disassociating and checking out
or stressed about things that I know are
going to get done either way yeah yeah
that's the thing about like other people
driving like I have uh someone in my
life who's like when my other family
members driving they'll be like stop go
now do this change it's like when you're
not here there you know they drive so
you know they are still alive yes so the
chances are that you they're not gonna
die and crash when you're in the car
right so if anything you're making that
the probability Higher by distracting
them from their normal routine right
yeah that is a weird way I've had that
thought process before we were like why
are I've gotten us this far it's the did
you die thought yeah did you die yeah
it's just like some people want that
control right because that's how they
survive is they control every or they
think that they control every little
variable but then it's like you don't
like so much of our Lives is outside of
our control yeah and to like try to have
control of everything is uh
it's a waste of energy right at best I
think the best we can do is take it back
where it gives us opportunities to if
you're in a red light you're gonna sit
there and mind them at least you're at
the red light or are you going to
do something do something on your phone
yeah ever since I learned that AI was a
better driver than humans I'm like I'm
not going to spend any time getting good
at this is it is it a benefit because I
know Tesla's having issues yeah like
they've killed a couple people and all
right ran in front of an 18 16 wheeler
like when it's like oh they can do this
like this isn't a skill like if a cow is
better at playing a plow than I am I'm
not going to spend all my human energies
holding a plow even though that is a
great exercise and it would make me
better at some things it's not like
something that you want to be the best
at so I'd rather like get good at
something like we're slowly shaving off
parts of the human experience like back
in the day or like oh if you can carry
two pails of water then you're an
amazing person but then we figured out
ditches and Wells and [ __ ] ditches over
I like that you're like the answer was a
hole in the ground closer to where you
were that's it that's brilliant who was
the first guy that was like we don't
even what if we just built one big
bucket in the ground
that was probably the thought they went
through today Wells plays such a
prominent part in every medieval movie
like that you hide in the well you meet
at the well
it's like you don't want to fall on the
well right thinking back now you
couldn't pay me to drink water from the
ground like I know especially if it was
sitting in a hole and everyone can spit
in it anyone can do anything they want
yeah I can [ __ ] over it if I want to I
could scratch my balls and flick the
pubes in there when I walk by and it
would look less conspicuous like a spit
usually they have a cover on it yeah but
man bugs
yeah roaches find a way to get my
restroom when the windows are closed I
don't know how they're getting in there
but I couldn't imagine what could you
imagine what are the other options that
that's the best option I guess straight
from the river to the tap uh
that's one thing I think about human
history that truly astonishes me is uh
how many times people were just like
we're gonna eat or drink this and I hope
I hope it's okay yeah when they tell us
like if you drink water at Barton Creek
right now you will die and your dogs
will die and everyone you love will die
if you touch that water yeah well we
polluted it and damned it up yeah but
you're telling me a fish didn't die
Upstream back then and a bear didn't
take a [ __ ] in the river and it's just
so we put like you know denim jeans and
then if I like dye and butter oil
yeah I would have started with motor oil
but I like that I like the build to
motor oil whatever that dye is to make
jeans blue indigo
because there's that thing in China the
river
they uh the river Downstream from where
they make the jeans is all blue or like
the denim blue wow
I have friends that work on the coast at
Dao
and the way they get around it is they
build channels next to the bay or next
to the Gulf so they're not dumping the
chemicals into the Gulf they're dumping
them into their channels that lead to
the Gulf
hopefully it's filtered out by the
floodplain just when it floods it all
empties out yeah it's uh and they're
making like propylene glycol and oil it
doesn't yeah just dumping it into the
ocean
that can't be good
they find like little micro beads and
Plastics and stuff
how good is a yacht trip that the guy is
like we got to keep doing this I gotta
keep going on my yacht I gotta keep
getting on that yacht
keep pumping the chemicals into the
ocean it's more expensive to find a
proper way to dispose them but if we do
that I lose two Yachts yeah
and it's just like what you want your
kids to see the ocean one day
or no it's not that great
yeah it's always colder than you thought
it would be yeah that's why I don't like
it one of the oceans is warmer like the
Atlantic Ocean is warmer at the Pacific
in the Atlantic every time we went to
the Pacific and I put my toes in it like
it's freezing yeah it's so big is that
why it's colder because of the size I
don't know I feel like it's all barred
the same thing it's all coming from the
same fridge down south
oh man yeah I mean uh what do you think
about global warming
I believe in global warming
I think about it
like you're you're on the scooter you're
gonna start to see the smog a little bit
more firsthand now because you're like
you're riding you're breathing it too
yeah I think in La it was the first time
I was ever like looking around and I was
like holy [ __ ] in the morning time 9 A.M
you can't see the mountains from like
LAX I was like oh my God and then you
realize it and you're like driving and
you want to roll your windows down
because it looks nice outside then you
look off in the distance you're like I'm
in that yeah I'm in there right now yeah
and I have like a wrap that's funny I
used to live in Sunset Park uh in
Brooklyn that's like south of uh
Manhattan yeah and you look at Manhattan
from this hill and you see the smog
around it and you're like okay I guess
I'm going there today let me go there
yeah let me go to that thing yeah it's
got to be doing something we can't just
be put pumping [ __ ] out and then it's
just like yeah it's fine like where in
life is that true where you can just do
whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah to
something and then it all works out like
we have no discipline we know like and
then one guy at that factory is making
most of the money yeah
I know there are cities like parts of
industrial China where it's like an
industrial city
that it is safer to vape tobacco like
PPG and nicotine it's cleaner than
breathing the air
like they did a study where they like
pulled the air through cotton balls in
the air from outside affected the cotton
balls more than like the air from The
Vape it's actually a sanitization device
to walk around China breathing in
through a vape atomizer that's crazy to
think about but is it the Vape taking
the air in from the outside yeah but
it's heating it up it's like I don't
know how it really is it's a scary
thought
that's one place I need to go I feel
like there's so many [ __ ] people yeah
it's like I'm I'm ignoring
a third of the world if I don't go see
what they've been up to they're all
insane yeah so you just meet one they
have some really cool National or like
landmarks that are yeah they have cities
I love how they design their cities I
love their High-Speed Rail that's in
China too efficient yeah okay
and you can go like does that connect
the entire country essentially yeah okay
I don't know I talk too much [ __ ] online
about China you made it feel comfortable
going to China
yeah I feel like I could get in trouble
out there if they watched It's I mean
you'd imagine they vet everybody that
comes into their country with the
surveillance they provide right yeah
like they would watch your podcast don't
you just like Google like a keyword
search they transcribe everything that
I've said and they like control F China
right do you think your surveillance
like surveilled while you're over there
if you went
honestly I don't think it would be a big
deal Ari shaffir went over there and I'm
sure he said some crazy [ __ ] but that
was like before right a lot of crazy
[ __ ] happened would you go to North
Korea to visit I would love to yeah yeah
how do you think that would go over
though
uh I think they would be like you better
be on your best behavior one false move
and you're going to be Brittany
greinered are you are you from South
Korea you're American though I'm born in
America okay yeah how would that do you
think there would be hesitance on them
for if you were South Korean trying to
come to North Korea really led a South
Korean into North Korea well yeah I mean
they're pretty stubborn they're like
you're our enemy you're our brother that
we don't like
it's like very Asian they're so stubborn
they're like we hate you like
philosophically like it's a top-down
approach we hate you therefore we're
gonna treat you like this this and this
they're not like oh let me see how I
feel around you they're like first of
all I hate you then let me figure out
how I'm gonna treat you
do you remember the auto Story the
fraternity guy that went over there and
got came back with a lobotomy yeah yeah
for stealing a propaganda flyer from the
floor he wasn't supposed to be on it's
like scrambled like scrambled egged his
brain
um Jeffrey dahmered him yeah yeah
backwards though because they were the
Asian ones and he was the one
yeah maybe that's what it was Revenge
yeah you remember what Dahmer did pour a
pour some coolant in your [ __ ] head
oh my God
that's crazy I mean I bet they figured
out what worked they're like these
Americans are too headstrong let's make
them obedient like us Asians
oh man
that's one place I think I'd have no
interest in ever going to yeah I mean
Dennis Rodman went
yeah but he's like his best friend or
whatever well he had to get to that
point by getting there first did he or
was it like just one of those weird
things where he's like sitting there in
his
private media room being like I like the
guy with the weird haircut and earrings
I want him here now I want to meet that
man I think that's the only NBA player
they could get like who else is gonna go
there and they love the NBA yeah
basketball's their thing yeah and it's
like American but not white people
American so they feel like it's not like
supporting
yeah I think the dietary issues in that
country are really interesting yeah like
they give the food today
oh really and they're smaller because of
the malnutrition through the generations
and in the 90s is when it happened they
used to be doing better than South Korea
really yeah food wise are just yeah and
everything wow 70s and that was before
the regime or like that's during the
regime the original one yeah they were
like a more democratic one they were the
one that was like more Humane like South
Korea had a military dictatorship they
would like jail yeah anyone that wasn't
uh fully supportive and students had
like rebellions and protests all the
time that they would be murdered wow and
a lot of the people that were in power
in South Korea were from the Japanese
when the Japanese colonized Korea they
were like the people that were like you
know Uncle Tom's right they were the
ones that were like you know selling out
Koreans to the Japanese and then is that
why the South Korean flag has some like
Japanese hints in there I don't think it
feels Japanese in a weird way yeah I
guess so the circle in the middle right
I don't know what the deal with that is
maybe but yeah like uh then Americans
came and they were like okay the people
that were here during the Japanese
imperialism you guys are in charge now
because they don't want to like change
anything they're like let's just keep it
the way it is and that's in Japan too
they just put the people that were in
charge in charge of it they didn't
change it at all wow
so the idea the idea is flipped
essentially yeah wow I didn't really
have a bad career and ever since the
Soviet Union fell
South North Korea's felon hard times
yeah I think they're really interesting
I think it's crazy that they're
shrinking
but then you go and you look at like a
World War One bunker and you think about
how tiny people must be like we can
change people if we want to in like two
generations just feed them yeah what do
you think about crispr
I think it's cool they found like a
virus that can work into your genes and
then replace certain parts of the gene
with whatever they want would you would
you crispr your own children
yeah if they figured it out and it was
relatively safe do you understand the
threat with that
well it's like we don't know what we're
doing to the yeah it's something we
changed our eye color but then their
butthole comes out weird yeah we don't
understand how much of the or if that
child went and had a child we wouldn't
understand what we did to the gym pool
it would be like this weird thing maybe
we messed up a huge linear we should
figure it out we shouldn't just like not
do it because we're afraid we're gonna
[ __ ] it up I think we should subscribe
to like Tuskegee air type
psychological studies again I think we
end up with people we don't really value
life yeah why don't we get the benefits
and not valuable why are we not up why
are we only applying the value of life
to the things we simply don't need it on
to progress us as a world yeah to make
five cent right cheeseburgers yeah it's
like why don't we figure out uh
I don't know why don't we figure out
what really makes people gay
or just create an army of LeBron James's
yeah how many bodies do you think we'd
have to go through to figure out
oh man
yeah it's a Chinese Body Experience
exhibit
that's a Rogan's doing a bit right now
about the right the body museum yeah
that's scary I who else there's someone
else I don't know if it's a comic or
someone's telling me they don't they
wait until the end of that exhibit the
last thing you see when you walk out the
door
yeah it tells you everything you just
saw was Chinese war criminals yeah it
doesn't tell you that until you pay your
money and finish by the way you just
you're supporting the regime yeah you
just saw everyone we hated and then you
have to take a flyer about how Taiwan is
not a country
[Laughter]
see what we're doing here yeah
Scientology for Chinese government
I mean Taiwan is great but it is like
America trying to [ __ ] with China
yeah they were funding Chiang Kai-shek
and they were like here we'll give you
weapons
Taiwan just legalized weed right
I don't know or is that Thailand is
Thailand really Italian was really
strict about that right like death
penalty stuff right like wasn't there a
dictator like pulling up on dirt bikes
to kill people who smoked weed I think
that was the Philippines okay yeah yeah
duterte yeah
that guy's badass
yeah I mean if you uh take for granted
that drug dealers are bad people yeah if
you just get over that oh cool or dirt
bikes and machine guns it's as small as
possible way to get around right and
video people you just like outside
mowing your lawn and the president of
the country pulls up and shoots you down
oh hey
uh yeah Thailand is now like one of the
weed capitals in the world and it's a
glush environment Lush and then it's
natural it's like from Thailand weed is
from there it's Thai stick is one of the
original genotype or genomes of weed
yeah there's like three things there's
like a
Middle Eastern like the Himalayan
there's the Thai stick and there's like
some like parts of Africa I forget what
it is but basically every weed from then
to now is
just crossed bread to that yeah from
those three strains and now they're
what's even crazier to see is that
culturally they're different so
different
that they've like we have basically five
ways to get high in America on weed
smoke it eat it dab it
put it in a pin
I'm probably missing one or two more
sure but like there it's like culturally
they're they're like smoking it
differently they're eating it
differently they're finding ways to
extract the THC differently it's kind of
neat yeah how many other ways are there
going to be to get high yeah
we should all like expand our culture
like everyone should be coming up with
their own ways depending on what
environment they're in
it's like Barbie like business Barbie
and right
Malibu Barbie
it's like humans have so many different
ways of being and it's amazing how how
much we can change depending on whether
we're in a jungle or a desert
yeah what do people in Thailand speak
Thai Thai could you imagine how going
over there on weed tourism get really
high and everyone around you speaking
Thai
like wow this [ __ ] really is good I
can't understand the word anybody's
saying yeah like yeah okay
yeah
Thailand's also the place where the lady
boys are yeah their boys are close to
men yeah they create them similarly
or maybe like they have like more people
in the middle like gender isn't really
that strict it's not like
so manly and so womanly everyone is sort
of in the middle really they don't have
gender ideals really set in I mean okay
but it's just like not as rigid or
whatever it's not as a it's not as edgy
to be in the middle yeah like here you
look at a guy like he works at Hot Topic
or something yeah and then over there
it's just like oh
is normal tie
I mean you talk about the Native
Americans they have like six genders
yeah before we came over here and put
blankets on them and killed them all
but uh put a blanket over your gender
yeah we don't want to say that [ __ ]
it's like there's just one gender that
fishes that's all they do I'm efficient
well I think like the trans thing is
like fine you should we should be open
and like empathy should be given to like
the people on the extremes not just like
to the people that we're all familiar
with like that's how you know how
empathetic you are as a society
um and I think overall like it's a
distraction from the real issues like
we'd rather talk about trans than about
reshaping the economy and redistributing
wealth and protecting medical rights for
people that's the craziest one to me
right now
is like that seems like something we had
to go out of our way like climate
control is always going to be a fight
uh but it's like there are some things
that are like this is still a fight
abortion yeah man I mean I I don't like
I just like I like it's just not our
choice it's not our point to make that I
don't think man yeah or anybody who is
in those situations about it's such a
unique individual experience it should
be your unique individual Choice yeah if
it's growing inside of you you should be
able to do what you want with it yeah if
you had a tumor That Grew eyes
like an off chance it's like yeah I want
that removed yeah I believe that's life
that's yeah that's what I identify as
I'm sexually attracted to tumors and if
you kill them then I'm really sad right
yeah I think it's once again it's an
education issue I think it's uh
Kanye on Lex Friedman the other day he
was like [ __ ] everything kids don't need
to learn anything it's all
indoctrination the only thing kids
should be ever taught is engineering
yeah I guess yeah
and I was like that's a different I
think we should be teaching there should
be more spirituality in schools
like uh that's tough though you could
because you can't tell a Southern
Evangelical Baptist that you're going to
teach your kids how to just be here now
oh my God it's gonna be really bad when
they're trying to be here now during an
hour-long service that they cannot
relate anything to on a sermon they
can't understand it wasn't until I was
25 went back to church and listened to
the sermon was like ah yeah yeah I still
can't remember that sermon
yeah I think I mean so much of it is
disassociating like we don't want people
to be in the moment in present we want
them
to be able to space out and not be
present
because then that makes it better easier
for us to treat you however we want if
you can disassociate and think about
something else while you're working at
Walmart or an office job then we don't
have to give you a good job or you know
you just you just sit in the corner and
not don't start a revolution right I
think Tick Tock should be banned
[Music]
I think it's like well the thing my
thing is like why should Tick Tock have
to be for the social good when oil
companies don't have to like why are we
like that's a good point you you can I
have to be able to meme whatever I want
but what about the air and the water
like they can do whatever they want for
profit like shouldn't Tick Tock and
Facebook just be able to make a profit
if they want to like why do they have to
do certain things certain ways
I think it's that social aspect yeah
which I I agree with it's a weird
governance I'm not a social media
company right yeah I'm not saying like
Facebook should be able to do whatever
they want I'm saying oil companies
shouldn't be able to do whatever they
want like you should extend that logic
to you know all Industries like it
should the social good should be a
factor and we should be able to be like
hey we don't want this guy polluting Our
Lake it's just like we could be like hey
we don't want this guy censored for
saying you know vaccines might not be
safe yeah I think that's a brilliant
counter argument to it all it's like how
are you going to tell Facebook I can't
put that I'm I'm not a fan of Jewish
people
but you're telling me this company can
go and dump oil in a sea that a country
relies on for the like the wildlife in
it yeah you're right it's so bizarre and
how that's not yeah comparison isn't
it's like a thicker line you know
because that's what they're doing to our
minds imagine what they've been doing to
the ocean
it's like what they've been doing in my
bank account
yeah I couldn't imagine uh it's
you're right it's such that's such a
weird thing but this is the only thing
we have we're like we can't control the
air or the lake or railroads all we can
control is hey on my phone I want to be
able to see Candace Owen say black
people should uh you know suffer more
and get we should torture them more to
get them to be yeah more productive
members Society it's like I I want to
see my memes right since they're [ __ ]
with our memes we're like how dare you
but we're lost to everything else it is
such a weird it's because you need an
oil change every six months and you look
at 5 000 memes in one thirty minute
sitting so it's like uh
we're so prehistoric our minds are so
[ __ ] done if if I'm gonna live in a
polluted environment and not be able to
watch the memes that I want to watch and
that's too much I'm not voting then yeah
I ain't gonna vote if I can't I don't
vote I'll be honest I tried two times
and I'm at a point now where I'm like
you know what clearly they don't want me
here
I'm honestly [ __ ] up I thought I'm
like I don't think I'm gonna make that
much of a difference anyways yeah
exactly and then they how many people
did they do that to right unless I can
talk to the people in front of me and
behind me in line there's no difference
to be made yeah that's what I do instead
of voting I go there and try to convince
people to vote the way I want them to
you know Marcus Oland yeah he's uh he
registered down here he's a comic uh
just saying it but uh it's a
he's a he's a knowledgeable guy he's a
really smart guy always appreciate his
take on anything he's really quick too
and he went he's like I'm gonna go vote
in Austin because I registered and I was
like okay local and he's like yeah and
then he pulled up the website and he was
reading to me he had already done it he
read through them all but every single
person's website
that's running for like mayor of Austin
and there is some crazy [ __ ] people
dude like it gets all the way down like
this one girl he said there was one
person sure vote her her website has an
issues page no one else had an issues
page he said it was so disorganized but
hers was great but then he gets all the
way down to the bottom of her issues
page and everything's like yeah it's
great it's rolling back you know let's
get women back their medical riots and
all this everything that makes sense and
then at the end it goes crazy talking
about how there's mind control efforts
done by the CIA and how like we have no
chance to actually think freely for
ourselves and how no one's lobbying
against that and I'm like oh my God he's
like yeah she's still the best option
for me to vote for though that's the
crazier thing the Mind Control candidate
yeah yeah that's like her one glimmer of
herself through her political platform
like a Facebook mom yeah Mama bears are
scary dude yeah they have a lot of power
yeah that's what uh they raise their
kids this guy said uh that's what went
wrong hasanabi that's what he said went
wrong with Andrew Tate is he pissed off
conservative moms like he's like women
or his [ __ ] who is Andrew Tate I lost
this kickboxer okay who has English and
American Roots he talks with like this
weird British accent and he's like sort
of like a alpha male like women aren't
[ __ ] they want to be dominated okay type
of guy and he's a big fan base yeah I
got a lot he got big really quickly and
then he got banned from everything okay
is he on parlor now or something like
that I don't know what he's doing that's
crazy but yeah he said that's what
happened is like even conservative moms
couldn't get on board it's like this is
too extreme like he just went too far
with it
if your Niche starts to pay you make
your money
but in the event that I think it doesn't
pay you but you find yourself in that
situation it's like readjust you know
and you're clearly doing something
that's too much I mean I don't like
censorship but I also think like if
you're saying [ __ ] up [ __ ] there
should be consequences like Kanye like
losing Adidas and losing whatever I
solely believe like I I think I was the
last I'm 26 we talked about Millennials
versus Jinn what was he yeah I'm the
last year of a millennial it's a 96 born
and I remember getting popped in the
mouth by my by my parents and by other
kids
because like conservatives will be like
back in my day we used to fist fight and
punch each other
like you you took away my Facebook
because I said that the Nazis should
have killed more Jews like you're
hurting my feelings yeah and that person
needs to be slapped so they know that
they were very dumb yeah like there
should be consequences because words are
powerful and they can do damage but also
now you can say that behind a keyboard
thing and like if I said that at school
you know there might be a group of
Jewish kids so take more than one of
them yeah
they're small okay and uh no it's you
would I don't I remember I called a kid
a dumbass in the lunch line when I was
in sixth grade and I stuck to it I was
like no you're you're a [ __ ] dumbass
he said you say it one more time it hits
you he's like the biggest kid in my
school this is actually funny I was 12.
his name was Ezekiel Kane shout out
we're good friends now easy Kane he's a
rapper and uh he uh he was trying to
start a gang at my school in Hearst
Texas and we had watched a couple of
informational videos about gangs and
whatever and I was like a little
conservative Philip Garcia was like
you're not starting a gang
so I like he was passing out sign up
lists for this game 12 year old [ __ ]
that's uh how you start again it's a
good signup list slapping the keyboard
out of our key the clipboard and every
chance I could I was like quit talking
to my friends dude you're not gonna [ __ ]
up the school I'm a sixth grader here
I'm in charge
because it was first through six it's
like a senior and um I remember one day
in the lunch line I told him I was like
hey man you're a really big dumbass for
trying to get that [ __ ] started I want
you to stop and then he was like call me
a dumbass one more time we're gonna
fight and then he was like six two I was
like five six at the time and it was
like swinging at his belt line going
crazy and uh fighting it out and the
lunch lady came and like picked us both
up by the back of our t-shirt big was
the sludge lady dude she's massive lunch
lady big you know you know what I mean
yeah like Matilda like she's eating the
principal in Matilda right she's eating
like four lunches every day of course
and then telling kids with no money you
gotta go home hungry she oh is one of
those schools no she was a sweetheart uh
she loved me uh everyone at that school
loved me because like one of three
brothers so everyone knew us all the
teachers and uh she picked us up or like
each of us like I'm like a foot off the
ground because I'm shorter and then easy
is like two inches off the ground she's
like walking us to the principal's
office and she throws Us in the chairs
in the principal's office she's like
these two are fighting in the lunch line
and then walked out and then easy goes
the misgalian
has passed away since she goes easy pull
up your pants Philip go back to class
and I was like
what you're not I'm not you're not gonna
call my parents or anything or tell
anybody because I was so excited that I
got my first fight yeah I went home I
told my parents over and over again like
okay Philip whatever I told my dad when
I got out of the car that day I was like
I'm getting in a fight today he's like
okay son
and then like two days went by of me at
the dinner table adamantly being just
like I got it fine I gotta fight I'm
like it happened you wanted to be
reprimanded so bad dude I just wanted to
be cool so bad and then eventually they
called the school like my mom and dad
called Miss Galley and was like did he
get this fight and Miss Galleon was like
oh yeah he did get in a fight a couple
days ago but it's okay he was standing
up for the right thing and I was like
this is so [ __ ] lame dude I'm just
this I want to be a badass they didn't
give you the satisfaction of getting you
in trouble I should have started again
I like your solution to gang violence
was violence I'm gonna fight this guy
who's trying to start violence at 12
years old I had the same confidence as a
36 year old Republican First Texas
pretty wise for those parts of town
you're saying like if you say if you say
stupid [ __ ] then you should get picked
up by
Mrs Zuckerberg
to the principal's office I think that
I think that people should have more
fear in them I think that we've
eliminated a lot of fear physically from
the world I don't think you should hit
people I'm never going to be the person
to do it I'm never going to be the
person to get anything you feel sad now
I think Kanye
I think Kanye is alone
I think he lacks a friendship I really
do I mean the the interview with Lex he
gets all that way and you hear like this
distrust in his voice and I think he
realizes at the end that when Lex is
like no I'm like and I'm here like to
let you have your platform and I'm here
to help you and I think he when he
realized Lex was being genuine in that
moment the interview changed and then
Kanye changed you think you see him like
levia and become a human being he's like
oh it's been a while since I've been on
a major media platform and it was he
forgot like it was a two and a half hour
podcast like it's just real there's no
filter here and
I think he's missing that I think he's
missing a system of checks and balances
with people that love and respect him
yeah that's ultimately what's going to
let you guys too much power nobody can
say anything to him and anytime anyone
does they're like who are you influenced
by because he doesn't have a genuine
friend yeah yeah
you got to keep your day ones around man
well that should be the end it's a good
message
day ones yeah yeah it is you got to be
checked and balanced 100
all right thanks guys